[Música]
un mar de tumbas se extiende hasta el
horizonte manaus vive su peor momento
desde el inicio de la pandemia en enero
la media de muertes por corona virus
duplicó la de mayo que fue el mes más
letal de 2020
[Música]
los empleados de este cementerio de
manaus nunca tuvieron tanto trabajo
cada vez más personas entierran a sus
entes queridos entre sollozos
este hombre perdió a su hijo
yo
realmente nunca llegó a mejorar
para los dos millones de habitantes de
esa ciudad amazónica todavía es difícil
ver la luz al final del túnel
[Aplausos]
hay mucha gente muriendo de comida en
los hospitales el gobernador es un
asesino porque ha dejado morir a todo el
mundo hermanados hay mucho dinero pero
tratan a nuestro pueblo de esta forma no
invierten el dinero en nuestra población
el cementerio de manaos intenta evitar
aquella imagen lamentable que el año
pasado dio la vuelta al mundo
esta área que era un campo está siendo
acondicionada para las víctimas del cob
y donde los familiares pueden tener un
acceso mejor acabaremos cosas colectivas
por determinación del alcalde sólo habrá
tumbas individuales
el tráfico de ataúdes es constante
la celeridad del ritmo de los sepelios
contrasta con la lentitud en el
abastecimiento de oxígeno
a unos 30 km del cementerio decenas de
personas se aglomeran frente a esta
fábrica
buscan el bien más preciado semana os
bombonas de oxígeno para sus seres
queridos para muchos es la diferencia
entre la vida y la muerte
desde el 14 de enero la falta de oxígeno
en manaos ha provocado la muerte por
asfixia de decenas de enfermos hasta hoy
no ha sido posible restablecer el
suministro para satisfacer una demanda
que crece cada día
esta es la única empresa que está
ayudando a la población de manaos en el
interior con el oxígeno para que podamos
llevarlo a nuestras casas para ganar
está claro por qué el gobernador wilson
lima es un genio
es un gasto prohibitivo para muchas
familias en el amazonas más de la mitad
de la población vive por debajo del
umbral de la pobreza se acabó el dinero
ya recibimos ayuda de desconocidos de
otros estados pero es muy caro una
bombona pequeña cuesta 75 dólares al
finalizar este reportaje unas 600
personas estaban a la espera de una cama
en el hospital de manaus david que ya se
curó de coronavirus lleva dos días
haciendo la cola tiene un buen motivo
intenta salvar a su padre que está muy
enferma tuve que correr debajo de la
lluvia con la bombona está siendo una
experiencia devastadora y al mismo
tiempo veo la solidaridad
este profesor de 40 años ha montado una
unidad de cuidados intensivos en su casa
la colocó aquí
isaías tiene 75 años desde hace 15 días
dhabi le cuida día y noche armado de un
oxímetro y de la bombona para los
momentos más críticos alquilamos este
equipo durante 10 días aquí controlo los
valores de oxígeno que estamos usando
que es lo más importante este cilindro
debe aguantar un par de días más
la escasez de oxígeno es evidente
incluso fuera del hospital
el ministerio estima que manaos llegará
a 100 muertes diarias si no se trasladan
de inmediato a 1500 pacientes hacia
otros estados de brasil
el sistema público de salud no se
preparó para esta segunda ola el
gobierno local es incompetente e
irresponsable falta transparencia e
incluso hubo corrupción
la mutación brasileña del virus presente
en el 91% de los casos detectados en el
amazon ha empeorado sensiblemente el
escenario
margaret al colmo es una de las
investigadoras más respetadas del país
nos confirma que la nueva cepa masónica
ya se ha diseminado por el territorio
brasileño y puede causar un aumento
significativo de los contagios la nueva
variante no es más virulenta y no causa
casos más graves o más muertes pero es
más transmisible incluso entre la
población más joven
estan neumóloga descarta que una crisis
del oxígeno como la de manaos puede
repetirse en otras ciudades según ella
solo la vacunación puede evitar un
colapso sanitario a nivel nacional no
deberíamos estar vacunando cerca de un
millón de personas por día y en brasil
tenemos capacidad para hacerlo más para
ellos pero para eso precisamos tener más
vacunas
tenemos una cantidad muy pequeña que
sólo cubre los profesionales sanitarios
y una parte de las personas por encima
de una determinada edad
el instituto de valdo cruz comenzará a
producir las vacunas en su laboratorio
de río de janeiro una vez que se realice
la transferencia de tecnología este paso
requiere una importante labor
diplomática que el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro está tardando en llevar a cabo